a high-ranking ally of the me2 movement
and critic of President Trump is
resigning as New York State Attorney
General because of allegations that he
physically and emotionally abused for
romantic partners the women told The New
Yorker magazine that Eric Schneiderman
subjected them to non-consensual
physical violence in a statement
Schneiderman denied assaulting anyone
and denied having any non-consensual sex
but did say he will step down today the
Democratic attorney general was one of
the first officials to take action
against Harvey Weinstein when he was
accused of sexual misconduct
Jericka Duncan is here with the new
accusations and the response to Rico
good morning good morning the Manhattan
district attorney's office says it has
now opened an investigation into the
allegations against Sneiderman The New
Yorker spoke to four women - who gave
their names and what the women alleged
is in direct contradiction to the cause
of Schneiderman has spent more than a
decade supporting if a woman does not
have the right to control her own body
she is not truly equal New York Attorney
General Eric Schneiderman built his
career as a liberal progressive who
stood up for women's rights but on
Monday in a New Yorker report the 63
year old was described as a dr. Jekyll
and mr. Hyde who was physically and
emotionally abusive in private toward
four women among them Michelle Manning
barish who told The New Yorker she began
a romantic relationship with
Schneiderman in 2013 that quickly turned
violent
she claimed he was a heavy drinker and
described one instance where he
allegedly called her a [ __ ] and
forcibly slapped her directly on her ear
he then allegedly used his body weight
to hold her down and began to choke her
we begun a long overdue recognition with
our culture of violence and silence
Tania Silva retinas said she met
Schneiderman in 2016 and described her
relationship with him as a fairy tale
that became a nightmare salva retina who
was born in Sri Lanka said Schneiderman
started calling her his brown slave and
would sometimes tell her to call him
master she alleged he would frequently
slap her across the face choke her and
spit on her it wasn't consensual she
said this wasn't sexual play-acting
Schneider
denies the abuse allegations saying in a
statement in the privacy of intimate
relationships I have engaged in
role-playing and other consensual sexual
activity the federal government has been
taken over by anti-choice anti women
extremists in recent years Sneiderman
has raised his profile by taking on
President Trump he has also been at the
forefront of the me2 movement filing a
civil rights lawsuit against Harvey
Weinstein in his company this report is
a major bombshell CBS News legal analyst
Ricky Clemens said the Weinstein
investigation likely won't be affected
by Schneiderman stepping down that case
stands on its own however if any of
these allegations against Eric
Schneiderman are true the hypocrisy is
beyond belief in a statement selva
retina confirmed her account in the new
yorker manning barish did not respond to
our request for comment Sneiderman
praised The New Yorker last month when
it won a Pulitzer Prize in part for its
Weinstein coverage he tweeted that
without the brave women and men who
spoke up about the sexual harassment
they endured at the hands of powerful
men there would not be the critical
national reckoning under way the New
York State Legislature will vote on a
new Attorney General to serve through
the start of the new term on January 1st
I think this is just so bizarre and
unlike a lot of the other cases he's
saying this was consensual these women
said they were in the relationship but
why be involved in something like that
was someone that's not also interested
in doing that apparently yeah it seems
like he needs a new definition of
consensual and role-playing I think
Ricky Clemens said it best when she said
the apparent hypocrisy is what has many
people shaking their head and looking at
him sideways like what what in the world
was going on in his life and these were
strong you know successful women that
basically say once again it becomes I'm
dealing with the powerful men who has a
lot to lose and the chief law
enforcement of New York yeah and right
now it's for women yeah drinka dr.
Kananga has come home to him that's
right thank you